bill's the man dude hey i just want to
say one more thing
what do you think when eddie murphy said
you you you [ __ ] a purple [ __ ] or a
green [ __ ]
eddie murphy on raw he's a captain
crooked [ __ ] green [ __ ]
all that green stuff comes off on you my
god
[Music]
why are we using these i can hear you
no i'm good all right yeah
this is cool so how come man what what
did you do with the fountain of youth
in your backyard what did i do what
with the fountain of youth do you look
oh i i drank it
in there they gave me a bottle yeah
fountain of youth i love you
you you're back in shape yes yes i'm are
you working out
yes i work out every morning i worked
out before i came here
you guys are ready to rock all right
i'll bring us in
they'll bring us our teas hey everybody
welcome to another episode of hot boxing
with mike tyson i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson and mike we've got
i mean what can we say status legend god
status man
william shatner welcome welcome to the
show you know i you
captain kirk in the in the course of uh
of a career you do a lot of these things
here but i've never
been so uh happy to be at one
thank you talking with you this is
really beautiful we appreciate that very
much well i've been admirer of mike's
for a long time
uh saw film on him when he was younger
and followed his career
with all as he went through his fights
and
and then the journey uh through his life
i've i've followed it pretty closely
so i'm excited to talk to you about it
awesome that's good
and of course you know we watched you
since dual puberty before puberty and
child
infancy yeah mike i have to say
william mr shatner sir bill
bill bill i i remember when i was
six or seven years old living in new
york city i was born in new york city
lived in brooklyn
my father was a painter an artist
and on this particular night i went into
the city with him to go to one of his
art openings
and afterward he took me to a video
store and he said ebb you can pick out
any video you want i said okay and at
that time it was still vhs
and i found one of the original star
trek
series a videotape it had like three
episodes were there any cleons on there
no but this one episode it became like
sort of an allegory for my life this man
captain kirk
had crash-landed on this planet and he
had to fight off these yeti like
bigfoot alien creatures and i was trying
to find what episode it was last
night but i couldn't find it but i have
to say i was like captain kirk is one of
the baddest ass dudes
i've ever seen beautiful childhood
memory of yours with your dad
absolutely a lot of people do that here
i saw it with my father and i said but
uh but my interest here this afternoon
uh is with uh you guys and with mike
tyson this um did you watch
any of the football games this this past
weekend
and i won't say which weekend and what
games there's even a lot about this guy
lamar
jackson yeah unbelievable that's exactly
where i was going what about him
that's exactly where i was going he's
another guy lamar just another guy to
try to
every so often in an era in a decade and
an
age an athlete emerges and you're like
that
is like one of the great that's what
human beings are supposed to be like
yeah physically yeah and when you came
out it was the same thing
here was a boxer whose talent was
limitless
lamar jackson is as a as a quarterback
whose talent you just didn't know the
limits he's just starting
your talents as a boxer was unknown
and and in everything
as an actor as an athlete who
rides uh whose sport now is uh
uh competing on horses in various
disciplines
but in every walk of life you need
you need the confirmation you need
whatever your body's
required to do you need the talent to
whatever it is you're doing
but most importantly you need the hunger
you need the rage you need
the the the intensity you need the
wanting
and the wanting can't be taught can't be
bought it's there
it's not there so uk he came out as a
boxer
and and that's where i wanted to go with
you
my my bewilderment
in fighting can i go there with you
please
please i i as a kid in school for a
number of reasons i was in a fight
two three times a day in montreal canada
i was defending myself and i had to take
on one two three people at a time
and somebody gave me a yearbook from my
high school that i hadn't seen
and my nickname was tuffy because i was
always in a fight
but the fights we were in especially in
the winter in canada
with your heavy overcoats and everything
you swing and you hit you know not much
happens
you're wrestling around on the ground
i've never been in an adult fight where
a guy has
got this as a weapon and wants to
knock me down and presumably the rage is
to kill i was in my makeup room and
i'd had a tussle with the guy with a
fellow actor
backstage he had said something and we
swung and we missed and was all okay
and he comes in my room and kicks the
door shut and we're locked in a room
together
okay and i am so angry that i'm looking
at his jugular
and i'm thinking i'll leap on him and
bite his jugular
that's how animal i had been and the
door opened up and they stopped this
from
from fighting that's as close as an
adult as i come to fighting really
yeah i have never had a guy
pound my face pound my body as an adult
who could kill me
that's the feeling i want to know about
and you saying
really like amazing like you've never
been on a fight my god
who hasn't been in a fight a lot of
people haven't been in a fight
well that's interesting because i
explained it to my wife i tell my wife i
said um
this during our period when we were just
really getting to know each other as a
married couple
and i said um you have to understand
what i did for a living
people avoid their whole entire life
that's right
yeah that's right that's the dichotomy
that's that and the the difference in
our
upbringing i know you came from the
streets i know you were a tough guy on
the streets
age 16. customato finds you you find
customato
you start boxing and this talent that
you had
but also the rage well
and perceived to be rage is is really
not rage
it's a perception of rage tell me about
that the art of fighting is not
fighting it's the perception of fighting
wow i i give me an example of it
okay
the perception of the person who what is
his name um
i don't know achilles the greatest
warrior of all
your perception is fighting him right
well
so the perception of fighting him would
be to run away unless
you knew that his heel that his
uh tendon in his heel was the only
vulnerable part of his body
exactly but in order to do that you have
to risk
the chance you have to run the circle
whatever it is you have to take that
risk
and that's what fighting's about taking
risk
okay so so let's not talk about the guys
in the ring
who now you know you're covering up and
you're jabbing
and you're not allowed to kick and you
can't
kick him in the balls and and you can't
use your fingers to poke his eyes out
things that on the street if you had to
save your life you might be doing
anything you can think of in the minimal
minimal amounts of stuff
that you've read about that are that are
hurtful or
or deadly you would be doing to save
your life
but now you're a kid and you're able to
kick and bite and
that is as primitive as the vikings with
their broadswords
the vikings with their broad before uh
guns when you had to face the enemy with
a knife
or a sword or your hands
does anybody ever forget that nobody
talks in history
of uh of uh battle fatigue
that's interesting you bring that up you
know you know how
um gladiators got discovered
during war and some of the captors
prisoners of war
um there um some of the some of the
other warriors
say i'm a greek and i caught some
persian so we're bored so we're not
fighting 24 hours
the war doesn't even last long 20
minutes before the winter was the war is
over
they they break up and they plan to
fight another war
so this scrimmage stuff but when they
catch some
persians or something so the greeks go
like they get bored
hey let's make them fight each other
and then they start fighting each other
and then they fight to the death
and then some of the guys the the greeks
give some of the persians some of the
winning of the money they made
and so they said wow i got money they
started the first time they're prisoners
now i'm
out there stopping now we're eating and
drinking from fighting and
i like fighting for entertainment yeah
i'm eating they gave me money
and so now this is how they created wars
and that's how gladiators got
created i understand now that's an
interesting phrase
i like fighting
do we know people who like fighting
absolutely
but they don't like hurting people isn't
that something yeah
so how do you how do you explain that
because you ought to hurt somebody
to win the fight right absolutely but
the fact is um
and you're talking about yourself no i'm
talking about fighters in general
but you in particular no i i like i like
the fact of hurting somebody in the
in them in the ring yeah that that was
scary for them
yeah for the opponent they knew that you
liked hurting them yeah and it's not
that i like hurting them
i like to portray the perception that i
like hurting people
so wait a minute you're talking about
several levels of
things going on you
you removed yourself from
absolutely liking to hurt somebody but
you wanted to give the perception
of liking to hurt somebody exactly but
in reality you didn't like to hurt
somebody
why did you like to give that perception
because with that perception he becomes
intimidated
uh intimidated yes you're the
intimidator
yeah by saying i'm gonna i'm gonna eat
your children
no but i'm thinking i'm gonna eat your
chicken that's what i mean not by saying
no you wouldn't eat their children
because they don't taste particular you
need a lot of
hot sauce the the but the perception
is all perception yes and so when you
said i'm going to tell him i'm going to
eat his kids
it was all i'm a beast and i'm coming in
the ring and i'm going to
and i'll start eating you first before i
eat your kids absolutely and some of my
some of my projects
um annex over the years he saw his
possibility i will leave his kids
but but wait a minute
i love that so you're
the first question is why do you want to
give that is to intimidate them
but but i'm going to eat your kids
is is like that goes beyond
absolutely and you meant it to go beyond
you were trying to think of the what's
the worst thing i can think of
to intimidate him probably yeah
but you wouldn't do that out of the ring
no did you never intimidate anybody out
of the ring
before boxing anything other to do than
with boxing
any other endeavor did you ever try to
intimidate somebody
i never knew an intimidated way i know
what i knew what intimidating it was but
i didn't know what it was
because i was always intimidated as a
kid i that's what i saw on the film
and that's what i wanted to talk to you
about the fear
because you were as afraid as
i am about being in a fight because i
don't want to get banged up and i don't
want to go to a hospital i don't want to
die
you're living on the streets and you're
fighting
for your life every day so you had to
did you use intimidation then
not much when i was a kid but i would
just fight somebody i wasn't um
aggressive yeah i was winning but i
wasn't a strong kid
and just um listen um this is really
weird
it just came to me naturally you're
fighting me when i didn't want to do it
it came to me naturally
even when i was scared to fight the guy
i might hit him enough and i break his
nose by accident
things stop stupid stuff like that no no
it's not stupid at all it's incredible
yeah because yeah because animals
don't think short horses have natural
instincts instincts to do whatever it is
supposed to do you can only teach a
horse or a dog
so much but if they've been bred to
uh heard sheep like like police
shepherds
they're particularly prone to listening
to orders and they
and they've been bred to do certain part
of our behavior
is is our genetic structure we're
probably half
half of what we are has been passed on
to us
whether it's a tendency to like
shellfish or
or to have a good right cross or
whatever it is
half of what we've got has been handed
to us from our parents
the other half is i don't think you get
much argument
that half is nurture in half as an agent
exactly listen i want to go to this
other level intimidation
i want you to get to the essence of a
consistency don't do that
so intimidation came i put i put that
out there
i mean you can i put intimidation out
there because i'm scared
so i want to talk to you about being
scared what does being scared mean
tell me what to give me an example of a
guy being
being afraid is an illusion
of your worst nightmare yes it's
coming true if you live to be a hundred
years old
what are you talking about here comes a
big guy what are you five eleven
five ten and a half five my height yeah
okay
five ten and a half and we fought for
every half inch yeah
so if i said 5 11 you had to be totally
honest you could have said
yeah i'm 5 11. but 5 10 and a half
because you're exact
exactly right okay i like
a guy six foot three is coming at you
yeah
that's fearful it is
but it's something that um i know even
though i'm only afraid because i'm human
but i'm not intimidated
even as a kid on the streets
no i'm not intimidated i'm afraid to
deaf but not intimidated
all right define for me what you mean by
being
you're afraid but you're not intimidated
because i would think that the two
being afraid is a feeling this is how i
feel because of this
yeah the feeling being intimidated but
that's just a feeling but this doesn't
stop me from acting
ah and being intimidated it makes you
being intimidated prevents me from
acting
yes if it puts it stops me it stops me
in my track
right like a deer in the headlight right
i can't perform at the highest level
that i normally perform because i'm
intimidated got it so you were afraid
but not intimidating never intimidated
i'm not afraid listen um
let's do it from a fighting term not
even a street turn let's go pop fighting
is not
israel i don't care who you are how big
you are what reputation you got if you
hit me i'ma hit you back
and i'm gonna hit you back with the
intentions of hurting you
most big guys don't expect that to come
back from people they expect a little
back but they don't expect people to
fight them to the end
uh-huh that's what i realized on the
street
huh on the street too
you know on the street they could be
instant in the street they could put a
gun with a knife
i'm talking about in the ring when it's
just you and another man
right and he and he throws his and you
throw your back
and he throws his and you don't stop
and you fight do you feel what he do you
feel it when he hits you do you feel it
sometimes does it hurt sometimes
mike i love you mike i just i love the
answers
i love i love your your uh
your passion your feeling your you
allowing yourself to open up the way
you are no um how can you be a fighter
if you're not
afraid fighters have to understand the
concept of dealing with fear
does that ever did cuss ever talk to you
about it absolutely i learned everything
i learned from customers so he talked
about fear and
oh my goodness i'd never thought that
would be a good people
they said they're not afraid they're
either insane or they're lying
right and that goes for
anybody in the ring fear them fears are
friend
fear is like fire you know i mean if you
um
if you're afraid of it and you let it
get out of control it can destroy you
and everything around you
but if you control it it can cook food
for you it can heat you keep you warm
it could be your friend it can fight for
you
[Music]
it's powerful power i saw you
what was the name was he a light
heavyweight that wonderful graceful man
who put his arm around your shoulders to
talk to you about fear he was
training with you uh he was either a
lightweight light heavyweight champion
remember
no you know i in that wonderful film
that i saw
he put his arm around you while you i
think you were crying
yeah he's my trainer he wasn't a fighter
he wasn't a fighter yeah what was his
name teddy atlas
teddy atlas but it wasn't just teddy
atlas
and his name i know he was
the light heavyweight no he was probably
the welderweight or lightweight i'm
sorry
you got it because he was champion and
he was with you and it was and it was
part of your training
and and he was in the ring with you and
he was teaching you at the same time
look it up because he he was
he was he was achilles
he was he was a warrior graceful
handsome man
and he had his arm around you and you
were 18
and you were weeping going into the ring
and i don't know what you were weeping
about
i always cry before i fight you did
always cry before yeah
what were you crying about i don't know
i'm just uh this is who i am
yeah but go further what's the emotion
are you you know i'm giving me the
change into somebody i don't like
you're getting ready to change you
change into the fighter yeah and you
don't like that fight not really
no not really wow mike
tyson that's illuminating
you are the greatest fighter that ever
lived
and you didn't like that guy
no because he came more with fighting he
what he brought more than just fighting
with him
what do you mean he brought like
jealousy envineness
guilt he brought a lot of stuff all the
bad qualities
yeah that you learned were bad yeah you
were assigned to that mike tyson
that isn't the mike tyson i'm talking no
no nothing at all
that's interesting no one ever you know
put that together but yeah that's who i
was everything that was bad was that guy
everything i remember from my past my
mother my fam
was that guy and and you were able to
cut him off at some point in time
he's tough to cut off he's my ego he
doesn't want to go
right so he's still with you yeah
he leads to a lesser degree or the same
degree in the control now by far
but but one that's in control or at
times
gets out of control i i hope not he
always sneaks up every now and then
let me tell you a moment that i had with
george foreman
i was in the ring with george foreman
yeah in a show that i did with him and
i traveled the world with george foreman
two years i had the best time with him
he's awesome
he's awesome so we're in thailand
and we're and they're in the boxing ring
and they go and they bring up
uh george and george goes in and they
all applaud because they're all
the thai fighters all know him and uh
and of course i
uh knew uh i'd known a little bit about
george at that point
know him a little bit better now but
they said
and i used to box uh as a kid or
just fooling around basically
but as the characters i played i
pretended i knew what to do and how to
shoot and he had a good physique
i had a good physique and i had the
technique yeah you know i i i punched
from the
from the hip but
so i get in the ring with george and
uh and i had talked a little bit about
george who said
basically the same thing that he liked
when he was younger he liked to hit
people he went into the ring to kill
somebody
he he wasn't two people he was in touch
with that other person
more when he was before he had this
transformation
so he said yeah i used to be a killer
but i
don't do that anymore now i'm dancing
around him and i'm popping him
and then i see the fire
you know sometimes you see a horror film
and they put a light in the
in the eye i see the eye light up
at the killers there for an instant i
looked into the killer
and then we did a pretend he swings at
me and i and i took it like a
movie player seen pictures of him in his
prime he's picking up with
uh a full-grown cow he was a bull he was
he was he was a [ __ ] and then
he had a transformation unlike anything
you've ever heard or maybe other people
have had
but it was an extraordinary moment so
that's the two
of mike tyson's yeah you have to look at
this this is really interesting
you're a fighter but this is
you know hurting people's interesting
but you go like this
the more you hurt someone the more the
people's gonna love you
the more you hurt somebody the more
people are gonna love you more
spectacular you hurt them the more
spectacular you knock them out
the more they're going to love you all
right and now i'm going to ask you i
don't know how this program along this
program is
but i'm going to ask you a question i
wanted your honesty and
in your your absolute uh
honesty your reality so i was in
in the in the uh arena uh
the the night uh you and um
holyfield holyfield i was there
uh as a guest of one of the sponsors i
guess
and i saw you fight and i saw you bite
him on the ear and then i said we all
saw the footage and all that kind of
thing
so linking up what you've just said
about mike tyson and the good and the
bad
who bit and why did you bite him on the
year
i was really out of control because he
kept butting my head
and he took me totally out of my game
plan which was um
was a really awesome plan and on his
back tell me what the plan was
well he took me off my game what was the
game what what did you go in
wanting to do constantly attack him and
punch me and constantly attack him
and um every time i came in he butted my
head
and i didn't care even though he butted
my hand because i was butting his head
back
but when he was butting me he was
cutting me you know
and i got mad because he was he on the
way i got mad i was almost
being a brat because i got mad you were
almost being a what a brat because i got
mad because
more than a brat my friend he was
beating me at being a better dirty
fighter than me
and i got pissed off because he was
getting away with
head butting you i was head butting him
too he's doing a better job than i was
so you you lost control yeah and
the guy that i looked into in that
dressing room
thinking i'll bite him on the jugular i
mean it's
total animal that's what you felt that
moment on the year no that's who we are
well we are that's where we are i know
what it happens to
i'm not using for excuses some people
when we go through this process
of um
what is it that we do when we come from
caveman to now what is that evolution
on this process of evolution some people
get more
some people get domesticated faster than
others
or somebody have some people have a
background
that doesn't lead to that domestication
right exactly but you know we all don't
get domestic at the same time
right you know some people have to learn
faster than others some more slower than
others
but that was a street fight maneuver
wasn't that no it was just um
undisciplined no no no no
michael michael biting somebody taking a
hunk of flesh out of somebody's ears
in the street it's a living and if
you're in a controlled
atmosphere like a controlled sport
that's just really undisciplined
right well i mean that's one word that's
one word for uh
to apply to it undisciplined the other
is
such rage that you knew
that you would get called for it i mean
you might not have been thinking then
that uh if i do this i'll get called for
it but
the the impulse to do it comes out of uh
absolutely yeah but it doesn't really
come out of rage it comes listen
in my situation it came out of me being
a [ __ ]
deck being mike and i can get it do
whatever i want it was my [ __ ]
i'm gonna kill you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it was it wasn't that yeah it was like
you [ __ ] and i bit them it
wasn't like
i'mma kill you [ __ ] so you mean
it was more calculated yeah
wow what do you think about that when
you think about
mike tyson who did that what what's your
thought about that this is what i think
do you notice a figure of mine just
fainted yeah
if you get passed out
yeah leave it alone i want to hear what
you were doing what you were going to do
and where were we at now we were at
mike tyson uh abiding
okay and yeah i bit him
but where did it come from it
it came from me um being a prima donna
i could do what the [ __ ] i want oh okay
you were you had been
the king of the world yeah and that went
to your head you think
no my um my lifestyle went through my
head what getting king of the world my
lifestyle went to my head that's what i
mean
as being you had everything yeah i can
do it you had monumental money
you had monumental women it wasn't that
because having all that i was still
empty that didn't fulfill my whole
it didn't no that stuff don't you're
still empty yeah
you know when you have a hole like that
you have to go something bigger than
yourself
what's and have you found that i don't
know it's um
it's me you know all that stuff that i
was doing that wasn't me
this is you yeah i had the discovery is
this you yeah i truly believe this is me
talking relating with doing business
absolutely i've never done this before
are you good at it seems to be i'm
pretty good at it i got you here
have you got the intuition
about people instincts about people i
don't know i'm comfortable with the
people i'm with
anybody outside of that that might be
pretty skeptical but
my my pretty much are you shy mike
in in certain cases maybe
basically then are you comfortable
being in a room with strangers or or uh
you would you rather not be there and
be with people you know if i can learn
from them i'd like to be around oh
i look at people as teachers i used to
look at people as competitors
or women as just um somebody i could
sleep with or
have a lovely encounter with but i look
at people now as my teachers
that's fantastic
wow it's good stuff good stuff
bill how about that
desire and that passion that we kicked
this thing off with talking about lamar
jackson maybe being
the nfl's version of a mike tyson this
this ultimate expression of humanity
through
athletic ability
i mean you have you're a cultural icon
man
like and you created this persona
of yourself did you bring that did you
have that passion and that desire
infused in your acting career you had to
there's no doubt
um you know i i don't recall
i mean i'm probably more passionate
about performing now
because i'm so busy and i'm um and i'm
running and i'm and uh and i'm thinking
this last two weeks for example
i when i started this last two weeks and
i had to go to uh
saudi arabia and then i had to go to
ticonderoga and then i had to go to new
york and then i went to ottawa and i
went
and i'm flying and i'm dying and i'm
trying and i'm driving and i'm talking
and i'm performing and
i'm thinking i don't know whether i can
do that
not only because i'm the age i am and
getting that heavy suitcase up into the
up into the thing up there with my
shoulders it's getting harder to do
in fact i know i'm getting old you know
how i'm getting old you know how i know
i'm getting older
can i help you sir i'm getting a lot of
that
what do you mean can i help you sir what
do i look like would you mind helping me
with this bag
excuse me would you mind helping me
getting the bag down i know i'm old
that's not just then um
i talked to george foreman not too long
last time i was at a
boxing event
you know it wasn't a boxing but just
like um hall of fame
something his award show and his
daughter had just died
and i was saying um i'm sorry about your
loss
and he was saying hey listen um i'm
happy to be alive to see a lot of things
is that what he said i sent him a a note
myself
i want his daughter that i wasn't around
i wouldn't be able to see this
and i was thinking that too and then so
you're right here and i'm saying i'm
holding 87.
somebody told me 23 87. am i 82 yeah
i'm in that area listen so what tell me
do you do you think about time
what do you think about dying all the
time yeah yeah
do you think it's going to be pretty
exciting no i think it is
i don't want to leave really well i'm
having too good a time
well i think listen and this is great um
death has to be
[ __ ] glorious no it can't be oh it's
it's just the cessation of all
of everything right i think that's when
we reach our highest um
plateau you mean in the moment of dying
i'm only when we no longer exist
that's our greatest let me let me uh
let's let us lead into that
okay let me tell you this story i
watched two deep sea divers
on in on uh on film and they're working
on
a um on the platform of an oil rig
so they're like 800 feet down they're in
hard suits they got and they've got the
umbilical cord
and there's a boat uh 800 feet up there
uh hovering over them being guided by
air
giving them air they're getting air from
the boat
getting air from the boat and
communication and everything it's their
umbilical cord
and the boat is hovering over them by
means of a computer so the computer is
running directly over them
and it turns left turns right
automatically computer goes out
the boat starts to drift the boat starts
to pull
the divers along with it as it's
drifting out one guy is clear of the
platform the other guy gets
caught in the platform and the boat boom
the umbilical cord on this guy stops
he's got
a can of oxygen gives him five minutes
of life
he clambers on top of the half
built platform lies on top sucks on the
oxygen
and meanwhile the other guy is saying
we've only got five minutes
to get him back it takes 34 minutes to
get him back
the the diver gets his body brings the
body
brings it to the the uh
the vehicle that's brought them down
gets him into it and they lock the doors
and and he's supposed to be dead
he's alive and when he comes to
all he can say is it's all right the
guy's name is tom
it's all right tom that's what he says
it's all
right and tom thinks he means he's okay
when he came to consciousness fully the
guy said no
i died and it's all right
was what he said and i thought i was
moved to tears
because to me it's going to be painful
to me you're going to be alone
to me it's the end of all the good
things all the wonder
you're sitting here you finally have
done it mike tyson you've got the
respect of the world you got the respect
of everybody around
you've got this wonderful business going
you've got it
you've got everything you want
peacefully why would you want to leave
you don't want to leave do you do you
wow do you want to leave why don't you
make it like it's frightening to leave
and go somewhere
i wrote a script in which the soldier
who was a brave man
has a heart attack has a near-death
experience and in this near-death
experience it isn't white clouds
and and angels it's the demons we've
got you come and then they pull them
back
the doctors pull them back and now
instead of being a brave man
he doesn't want to die i'm a coward he
leaves his wife and children
in jeopardy because he doesn't want to
die he's afraid of dying
that's the story i wrote that's
interesting but i
think this is all an illusion you're not
afraid of dying
no i was i wasn't one time no no no
because you found what because i found
like
how could we have glorious moments in
life and not have it in death
how why would god allow us to be born to
make us feel miserable to make
us have fear of dying you know we have
more in tune with an earthworm
than anything else or g our dna is like
55
of an earthworm and trees and and us
have the same
we're all linked i know we're all the
ones all one
we're all one so does the earthworm
gonna live
uh forever and have an afterlife
my dog my beloved dog hey listen maybe
that earthworm
the fact that you encountered him you
saw maybe your mother maybe somebody
that's dead and trying to see you
well that's another possible
reincarnation we see and we step on get
away from it
that's your relationship with your
mother yeah
gotcha ma finally no that's my face me
son i love this i'm so happy you're
successful look at this
never mind away from me shut the [ __ ] up
we may come back as a rock imagine
coming back to the rock
well granite is supposed to have some
some uh
lifelike qualities my point is
if there's an afterlife for us isn't
there an afterlife for the earthworm
listen i say that too i say listen i'm
just i'm
at my son's baseball game and i'm
watching some answers it's around the
time of the year when they're about to
die
it's getting cold so i'm looking at
these hands and i tell my wife i say
look at his ass i said
what they what they accomplished in what
two months
the summer of the spring we couldn't
accomplish in a lifetime
but that's exactly right right and then
i said just like we're watching them
there's somebody watching us and if you
don't believe that
then you're if that's why they made the
ego
to believe that we're there's nothing
bigger than us
well there may very well be a lot of
things bigger than us but
it seems to be that when you go you're
gone in your present form
and you may have another life in another
universe
but the things you love here don't seem
to
come back i mean we're interesting you
say love because love is um
love super seeks our existence if we go
into that level now
well i'm not i don't know about that
yeah lovely love superstition well love
in making the earth making the world
forget that my love for somebody would
laugh forever and they would know about
my love my love would be known for that
well that's a romantic idea but
the people who loved you and who are now
dead
i know they love me well because you've
had the sensation
when you die that their love for you
will have died as well because that's
your memory of that
no i've died before since i've came in
and gotten um
listen since i've been in this
organization and i've engaged um my
relationship with my victim in my
apartment
i've died probably nine times already
yeah give me one instance of dying once
dying is
using a very ancient um medicine
you used yeah called the toad uh spell
that
t-o-a-d-d-m oh the poison from the toad
yeah the
the tone you took that i thought oh did
i yeah
and what happened and i died and what
was what
where what how do you know what did you
see or what did you feel
in your death i didn't see anything i
felt everything what did you feel
i felt that um
i felt that i was afraid afraid i felt
that all everything i did my whole life
was because of fair base
and i realized i don't want no one to
see i don't want to be that afraid of
the boy where everybody could pick beat
me up and do whatever they want to me
you had a deep
insight into yourself yeah well why well
that doesn't sound like dying that
sounds like living
no no to get to that to get to that um
to get to that moment you had to die my
ego death my ego died
i see and um it's only a 20 minute
i know but you know around 10 000 years
of experience
yes that's fantastic i i'm too
cowardly to experience that because i
don't want to go on a bad trip
well yeah you do have some bad trips
sometimes yeah
that's that's where i don't want to lose
control of at least
my the fear i have i'm in control of it
up to a certain point except in the
middle of the night when you wake up
and think i'm going to die and what's
going to happen um since i've been
thinking into i don't even think about
dying i think i'm fine being glorious
how old are you
i'm 53. how are you doing physically the
best shape i've been in yeah
you don't hurt i haven't heard but you
got to take some of your stuff
yeah do that do you really yeah yeah
yeah i feel better than i felt probably
in 30 years
your back doesn't hurt my back hurt but
it's hurt because of
a lot of hard work but when i use my um
copper gel is good it's good it's just
sometimes i don't know when to stop
working i do it too much it gets like a
drug and
next thing i know something i hurt
myself
oh that's fantastic so you've done
you've gone into your
psyche nine times yes
and each time you died had a a
resurrection
in a realization exactly and came back
you know
richer for it yeah i had one experience
i thought i was the baddest man on the
planet i was going through that
[ __ ] that i'm almost like i'm gone how
can anybody stop me and then i met the
god of war
and then i found out and then you met
the god of war
and then i just dissolved in his
presence i couldn't even i couldn't even
match being invincible in his presence
so everything do you think of yourself
as a warrior that as a
an ancient warrior as a throb as a
war reincarnated again and again were
you a warrior
my ego tells me that well you're either
part of it
my ego tells me that you know but then
my ego tells me this
if you're gonna take the um if you're
gonna take the warriors um
ideology you need a body you need to
kill somebody
so but you could take the warrior
ideology and not
kill somebody you could just be noble
and and
truthful but that's not the warriors
ideology
to be nobody know that so that's not
really the warrior's ideology the
warrior's ideology is to get the
stay alive to stay alive become the best
he could possibly be by only doing that
he has to challenge the best
to kill as many people as possible yes
well
i i guess the interpretation of the word
warriors
there's nothing there's nothing noble
about a warrior
i i was taking it i guess from the
ideals of uh
king arthur and and the whole romantic
idea
those guys those guys were robbers and
criminals yes
yes in reality that's what they were
the the age of um shivering chivalry
exactly that isn't
necessarily what a warrior is yeah
wow mike this has been incredible
definitely you calling a halt to
proceedings at all no this place goes on
for hours we go
we go for a little while but i mean
robin's we had all those guys man but
nobody like you captain kirk
captain kirk man it must be hard to even
know you had tj hockey
well you're hung up on how about the
twilight zone what
how about the twilight zone man one of
the old man he's right
well that's twilight you know from uh
prior to captain kirk i was a popular
actor in
canada and then a popular actor on live
television in the states and then
in the on broadway uh so i had a good
career going prior to
captain kirk then subsequent to captain
kirk a lot of things have happened and
so i i've in my mind i've gone way
beyond that
and in certain other people's minds
because they they
had a an experience with the character
they were either watching the show at a
very young age or a lot of people have
watched the show with parents who are
now dead
and it reminds them of their childhood
experience
who's the oldest celebrity you ever met
like who's the oldest famous person like
a vaudevillian that you met like george
burns or somebody who's older
probably uh leonard nimoy he did a movie
where he went back in time and i told
him
uh leonard you're old when you go back
in time and you still look old
that's really old uh he was about my age
i went from being as you did the
youngest guy in the room
yeah you're only what to being the
oldest guy in a room i don't know when
that happened
yeah but it puts you in perspective you
know as i see myself
in pictures getting older because i
don't like to look in the mirror and
stuff and there's something looking like
i look at myself and i said wow
you're stuck in time you can't believe
you even look like that was me
right yeah yes well but right you know
frightening you're looking elegant with
your gray beard
if you create that off you'd lose a lot
of years
i would never shave it off but why
why wouldn't you shave i don't like
beards you don't women
i knew i i asked a guy with a beard his
wife was
there and i said to her do you like the
beard
because you know you ever kiss a guy or
rub your mouth
christmas you know i don't want that
next to me so i'm always shaving when
i'm
going to see somebody i always shave
yeah but so
i said to the his wife you like the
beard
and she went no she hated it
and that's why i do it i do it for i
don't want no woman to think i'm
attractive
you're still handsome because you're an
attractive man
i don't want a woman to look at me that
way
you don't want a woman to look at you
that way yeah why not i just don't know
i'm not interested in that oh you don't
want to get into that
yeah i'm not interested you don't want
to be tempted yeah i don't want
temptation yeah
it's temptation not having to be
what not having the beard it would be
temptation i might think that
calling right calling upon temptation
calling upon temptation
so you're fighting that temptation
i'm not fighting and i'm controlling it
you're controlling that temptation of
other women yeah no i don't want anybody
to have no idea of anything well you had
a terrible experience with another
you you had the worst experience you had
the you had the
the the male uh human beings nightmare
no i didn't i had the best experience in
the world all right tell me about that
that was just a great experience come on
no
i don't know that's that's dealing with
my feelings
that's all of our feelings you know what
i mean all of us as men
were afraid of not being looked at as
men
that's your feeling too and being
stripped of your dignity by another man
or even by a woman that's our biggest
fear that's our quote-unquote tough guy
biggest fear to have another man
humiliated this whole woman
the fact of us being humiliated less
than being who we
perceive ourselves for being in front of
were you humiliated by her
no no i don't think i was no but i
i was humiliated you were i was in love
you were
yeah that's the only way i was familiar
because i was in love but does that not
uh then make you
redefine the word love i never defined
it
well you were yearning for it it was
just a feeling
right but what was the feeling you had a
hole
and you wanted it filled with that kind
of love which is
included maternal love right i don't
believe it with that
it was my egos my greed selfishness
oh man i perceived that oh no no no no
every human beings you know that
experiment they had with uh
with uh chimpanzees they took
chimpanzees i saw that experience
and they went to the basement they went
yeah they wanted to be held more than
they wanted to eat
yeah they ate two but they well but they
went to be cuddled first
yeah but literally because this is
something that you have to understand
since you're being given a dissertation
is this what you once you've been
once you're in love and once you go
through the dark side of love which is
betrayal
you never love the same again because
you're always on guard
and your and your your virginity has
been ruined
be kind yeah it changes your life
absolutely absolutely i have to be very
careful with my engagements with women
absolutely we are well in this new age
we all have to about what we
say and do and what was what was an arm
around the shoulder
and friendliness becomes uh uh
an attack it becomes uh
harassment but that's very interesting
no no
it's a possibility killing you because i
love you than killing you because
i don't know you and you suing me he's a
better person
i'm gonna kill you because i love you
didn't kill you because you sued me it
was some
i tapped you or did something yeah
yeah it's confusing
it's very simple it's very simple
don't hurt me [ __ ] it's very simple
i'll kill you
better i will kill you yeah but but
michael i don't like hey you can't
ration with my feelings don't rest don't
even try it please
don't harass me from my feelings i'm not
going to i'm not going to change your
feelings
if you're failing my feelings i'll kill
you because you don't want to change
your fee
you don't want your feelings interrupted
or
explained or changed no because
it might make you feel badly about
yourself no i already
there's nobody i feel worse bad about
myself worse than anybody i could ever
feel bad about yes i see that nobody
could beat me at worst can i beat myself
i understand that
so you jealously guard being hurt in
that way you don't need to be hurt that
way anymore
i prefer um love being hurt that way
yeah well michael nobody will ever hurt
you that way again
well i won't let them hurt me that well
that too won't happen that won't happen
but people now see you for the
who you are this this enormous part of
you
that is now there that i'm talking to
is this great human being we all have
i don't know about great human beings
well i'm telling you from my perception
i'm discovering right now this is my
feeling don't make me bless you
absolutely right
you're right absolutely right
my feeling towards you is you're an
incredible human being
because you went through the cycle
people that haven't gone through the
cycle
don't know about this other party of
their nature
but it's all around us we're we have
this reptilian brain i worry about my
children
and i look at them i have this my one
they all went to grade school my one son
got these um
invitations from yale harvey prince all
these great schools and i said wow
what's gonna happen when this guy falls
in love will he throw all this stuff
away
you know yeah because
our emotions are our most powerful
uh element our emotions are nothing but
illusions
the illusion they make us believe this
is going to happen but really it's not
going to happen
if i do this i'm against our emotions
are buried
in us that need to be fed and if they're
not
fed they result in other emotions that
you don't recognize
so your lack of early love
started you on a point of your career
point of your life that gave you a
certain angle your intelligence
monitoring those impulses gave you
another intelligence
and we all have that to one degree or
another the reptilian brain
and the the frontal ego is our war all
the time
there's no doubt and it also uses
it uses love as a game as a tool for a
game
you ever meditate bill meditate yep i
try
yeah i tried to meditate on my breath i
had a good yeah on my i have a great
so you got an app mike i'm on some
meditation music fourth blogger two
oh oh yeah you know it's the best
meditation frequencies
a little tincture of this stuff cbd a
cbc
yeah that's my new sleep potion that's
great it's great stuff
yeah i meditate every day meditation
do what what is your meditation method
what is the
methodology i sit
um in a chair that allows my hips to be
higher than my knees
so that i can have it higher than your
an erect spine
so i feel as though a string
is pulling the top of my head straight
so you're not you're not
caved in exactly i'm not like slouched
at all
my feet are flat on the ground and i
just begin to focus on my breath
in the nose out the nose and as
our minds are wired to just constantly
be figuring out
[ __ ] analyzing data keeping us
alive you know that reptilian brain etc
is all happening constantly especially
in this digital age where we have this
you know these phones and [ __ ]
technology and that we're just
constantly bombarded by
stimuli so your mind is going to wander
now the practice of meditation for me
becomes
as thoughts come up as memories come up
i acknowledge them and i bring my focus
back to my breath
and it becomes that constant practice
and then i'm meditating yeah the the
impulse is of course to fall asleep
yeah you got to avoid that well that's
not bad either
well do you have difficulty going to
sleep
no but once i wake up i stay up all
night like i might go to bed
seven o'clock i wake up at one
yeah not going back to sleep so i may
smoke some weed i go downstairs
drink some tea watch some television to
like two maybe three o'clock
and then i get on the bike at three
o'clock in the morning yeah do the bike
for an hour now look
just what you just did there was like
intense yeah
very intense intense so let's say 30
minutes in 30 minutes i may do
300 calories i burn 300 calories in 30
minutes
close to 290 to something like that get
a good sweat on
um like somebody is dusting me with
water then i get
that girl for that and then i might get
on the treadmill for an hour
and get 400 calories let me go to and do
something
do little weights wait yeah feel the
exercise
i'm in a pool nice pool and i keep it
warm so it's pleasant to go in
nice and so i go in there and
a great um
uh bone surgeon i don't know what you
call them uh
orthopedic surgeon or the pities are
perfect uh dr clapper do you know him i
don't know clapper he had a radio show
on for
uh saturday mornings for a long time in
l.a yeah he's one of the best
so uh and he's become a buddy uh after
two hips
um two trips to two hips
anyway you become a buddy comes up for
monday night football and that kind of
thing
he said if you walk forward and backward
in a swimming pool
just walk forward and backward for half
an hour that's all the exercise you need
to do
you'll be in shape and you'll be
loosened up interesting yeah
water is very powerful very powerful it
and it takes the
onus off your joints yeah that's what i
did i did that this morning put some
epsom salt and some hot water in my
bathtub yeah that's awesome and i have
to be in pain though
to get in the bathtub because the last
thing i want to mess with the hot water
and the sub
and sometimes you just got to get in
there yeah yeah
and then the 100 100 different yeah oh
definitely why didn't i do this
so rejuvenating
all that trouble with the hot water a
hot a warm swimming pool
does it all yeah definitely shower and
all that stuff and you're a football fan
big
time football fan and and horses horses
that's right i do a lot of great work
a lot of well i do uh i do a charity
what's your favorite every year the
hollywood charity horse show when is
your favorite horseman breed so i breed
three types of horses i breed a standard
bread
a trotting horse i breed a american
saddle bread
high going show horse and quarter horses
in which i i compete on all three and
have one world championships
and the other two right and once i'm i'm
up there as a i i've got the potential
of winning
wherever i go because i've got the
horses not necessarily because of my
skill
although over the years i've become more
skillful than
than most it's awesome i like this horse
called um a cold techie you ever hear
that
say it again a cold techie a kale
techie put it up there yeah this is the
horse that i'm i'm gonna
purchase you uh uh a thoroughbred
yeah you call them that well i mean is
he a running horse
you use them to run they can run they
can be raised too but i don't think that
um the american thoroughbred american
thoroughbred yeah
they're um turkish standard turkish stan
stein they're from turkistan stein
and what what is it what's it look like
it's
it has no fat no subpoena fat it's just
a pure muscle horse
and it has and it glows in the dark it's
it's um it had metallic fur
which is uh a cold techie
i fell in love and it's a breed of horse
the most beautiful horse in the world
it's the oldest breed in the world
no kidding oh it's so beautiful i saw
the horse i hate horses never like
tossed in my last thing just i fell in
love with it
never like how could you hate horses
never liked us you never because you
were
it's a little one stepped on my foot
yeah it makes you afraid oh yeah look
how beautiful
oh god oh look at that that's the way i
feel about my horse that's beautiful
that is so beautiful look at his muscles
oh my god look at that there's a bunch
of fat on him
he's a little thin actually yeah great
way oh my goodness
and and i shine see the first shine i've
never known that
first shines like that the so it's in
aquil techno is that look at when the
black and brown ones are called
techie oh my goodness that's wild oh
this is beautiful
that is gorgeous my goodness
and they're a riding horse yes unless i
saw a guy playing with one he was boxing
with it and it was boxing back with him
i said oh man i said i want to get that
did you get it i'm going to
where are you going to have it in las
vegas i don't know i put them in my
backyard i forget i'm just going to get
them first
michael i'm going to invite you to come
to our
to the uh not only my horse show here in
los angeles
but there's one of the big ones take
place in las vegas
so i'm there every year at south point
oh look at this is so cool oh it's
exciting
you know that is exciting whoa
rocket tech horse lying on the sand
they're around five
they fought against the russian empire
so the russians kept them
after you know with the church well for
goodness sakes
well i'll need that i want to look that
one up that's
and they don't import them here but
you're getting one well i think people
have them in this people oh really
i looked at my american um i called
techie called that
one from turkistan turkistan
that's that's wonderful that's great
well the horses are my passion
look at that oh my gosh it looks like a
statue doesn't it
wow yeah and look at the to a mess that
was yeah
stuff and look at that with the dappling
that's the most unusual coloring i've
ever seen i've never seen that
golden horse looks like a statue
the most beautiful i i took i was on the
app i said
show me the beautiful animals in the
world and that horse was wonderful
yeah no question look at that silver one
that one is beautiful god
damn beautiful woman
it it is true that's a beautiful lady
yeah extraordinary horse tall she is
beautiful body are we talking about the
girl or the horse of course
that's gonna mean nothing compared to
that horse
wow that's god when he's showing off huh
that's right well i mean look at the
beauty all around it
the woman is beautiful the town look a
beautiful that town is the
beside the water on the horse the whole
thing
is beautiful as beautiful as man-made
because those are cool man-made horses
as well look at that man
that golden color it's beautiful
yeah i've had a i had many lifetime
experiences
on horses i've almost died with a horse
rolled on me
wow i've won yeah they'll break
everything broke my leg
uh i've won world championships when i
thought i don't know whether i could
ever be happier than what i'm just
talking about world champions but you
win that it's the best you can be it's
the best
it's incredible i feel about the our
cannabis business let's win in the um
the cups and all that the microphone um
us wearing all the cannabis cups and all
this stuff that makes me feel really
proud
and um i like our brand
tyson ranch is just um it's blowing up
and it's just going all over the world
and we're going to um
we're the harlan and opening up in
holland and i'm just really proud i
don't know what to do
you're opening up with amsterdam for
that i was in amsterdam
a couple of years ago uh with my wife
and
it was during the winter and uh we're
walking the streets streets are empty
during the winter there's nobody there
yeah but the girls are all in their
booths and
people are hawking uh uh drugs uh and
we're the only tourists
i said we gotta get out of here we're
the mom
we're the ones everybody's after
i love the people i love dutch people oh
yeah the dutch yeah
never been man yeah no it's beautiful
beautiful beyond belief
walk the streets definitely you gotta
get there see they got the little um
where you have your boats you know you
can roll your boats in the middle of
town
that's awesome well bill you're still
performing
are we continuing on we're about to wrap
it up
i would if i were you we're doing so
well yeah man
i'm busy performing i've um yeah just
let's shout out to you i've got a new
show uh called uh the unexpected
the unexplained it's also unexpected
that it's such a hit
uh they ordered eight and then they saw
a couple and
um and uh they ordered 20 more hours
uh which is unheard of so 28 hours for
the first season
so it seems to be uh uh really going
well
the unexplained uh got a couple more
shows that i'm
just i believe i've sold uh i'll make an
announcement in the next few weeks
um i have in my phone
a sizzle reel which is a part of a sales
tool
uh you you so you bring the explanation
of the show and you have a little film
on the show
as sales tools to sell to people who
might might buy it
so i've got i i rode uh
a new motorcycle motorcycle absolutely
a new design a couple of years ago this
happened
uh and i drove that motorcycle from
chicago to l.a
it took eight days and we drove with the
american legion
and various other people so i was
raising money for the american legion
their their college fund and i was
shooting a documentary
of the ride which i called the ride and
we were also trying to sell that new
motorcycle
so there was a lot going on and i've got
in my phone the sizzle reel
that i'm going around now trying to sell
uh
the ride um plus
uh other things that many i'm i'm really
busy and
really doing a lot of work is there too
much work it feels sometimes you get
tired sometimes
you don't know where you wake up you
think you're home in another country
for the last many months i wake up and i
think
oh yeah i'm home or where am i and i
don't panic what time it is
what time is it oh my god i was just in
uh
riyadh saudi arabia last week
and then back east until sunday um yeah
it used to frighten me like where am i
oh my god now where am i okay i don't
need to be frightened
it'll take a few moments before i
realize where i am so
not only do i not know where i am i've
gotten to the point where i don't get
frightened not knowing where i'm at
that's good yeah turn that corner
somewhere where
it's nine o'clock at night and it looks
like it looks outside now yeah
exactly like what the hell we're walking
outside at
10 o'clock at night and it looks like
are you traveling a lot
yes what are you doing are you lecturing
i do some my lectures i do some of my
autograph
signings yeah and then i just um go
around just
for my daughter for tennis yeah i have a
young daughter that's 10 years old and
she's training to become a pro tennis
player
so we go to france we go wait a minute
she's she's uh
uh she's 10 years old and blank dennis
yes she's she's
athena she has your into your
uh hang guy hand eye coordination well i
don't know what she has she's got your
athleticism good
yeah she's good i've got a 14 year old
doing the same thing yes
she's really good she really likes
playing and
has she got the rage she hasn't
developed that yet
she has a different lifestyle listen um
i have the rage because if i fail i fail
right go back to brownville right she
failed she's still got a big mansion in
the living room she has a big pool
a big car driving exactly it was a
different very difficult to have the
hunger
when you're you have to have some people
um
let me tell you something funny like you
look at muhammad ali right
has both mother father happy home happy
family
never poor middle class but he had the
desire to be the best in something
yeah listen best fighter in the history
of the world right
i don't think he ever had a street fight
who i don't think muhammad ali ever had
a street fight
right right really that his man right i
i i
i know louisville where he comes from um
gene killer told me this
it's this guy that's the bouncer he's
the scariest guy in louisville he knocks
out guys in the end of
because he's bouncing and the clubs all
the time so he signed up the fight in
the boxing tournament the amateur
championship
and not leasing there he's the scariest
guy so i'll he gotta box him
so at least scared that that's at least
just pinned him with the jab
you know but he breaks the guy's nose
the guy got two black guys he beats the
guy real easy
and so he's scared ali goes in the house
and never comes back outside
because he's scared the guy's going to
get him and that's what jean kim said
the guy had to come to knock his hands
okay you're a great fighter yes
but um he never really you know he
wasn't the right kid so where did that
hunger come from
exactly interesting of himself hey what
his illusion of himself
that he was the greatest yeah
he bought into the illusion and that's
what that's what all this is about
our illusion of ourself our illusion is
being a scumbag losing being a rough
ruthless whatever our illusion of being
a caretaker
in loving people you know our illusion
of who we are
and and and michael is it do you believe
that it's all
illusion as to who we are or do we know
who we are ever
well i always ask people this question i
have a chance to say something
it was this person that's they
discovered a
fossil of lucy that's 4.4 million years
old
yes and so can you fathom the first you
the first man first gotta
put that seed in your family gene the
first that started the shat in the
family even though it was a different
name but started that bloodline
who was he what color was he 4.4 million
years ago what
do you think he was well you know it was
losing huh
we knew we know it's a little nut brown
lucy yeah but it was 4.4 million
and that wasn't the first person right
that's just the person they happened to
find
right who was her mother who was her
great-great-grandmother right
exactly so um that's really interesting
so who are we
see i i'm under the illusion we really
don't know who we are i i'm under the
impression
we really don't know who we are that
it's all an illusion we like to think
we're there so we think we're
we're we're really bad but we're really
good but we're good and bad
but what is what is good and bad who's
what's the definition of good and bad
well do you know there were tribes in
the the
the sahara sahara desert was one of the
big deserts
tribes living in such
precarious circumstances that life and
death was very close
when you couldn't fulfill uh
something to help the tribe whether you
were young or old
go die yeah so the old when they
couldn't do
any more wandered off into the desert
and died
that was their custom that was good now
you'd say are you crazy
told your parents wander off in the dead
you didn't put them in a home
are you mad what's the matter with you
you're bad
so the whole your definition of bad and
good
that was in sapiens the book have you
read that
i might i must have but uh but i've read
that in
yeah and tribe dragonball behavior yes
but if you just examine what people
think is good and what people think is
bad
changes all the time yeah and always say
that about our age you know julius
caesar said this is how old we are
but say how did alexander the great say
how old he was how did he determine his
age
how do you determine what like julius c
the determined 365 days of the year yeah
yeah
so with alexander the great is like a
couple of hundred years before caesar
how did he determine his age well
they all knew that it took 24 hours for
cycles of the world to turn and it was
all based on that
uh 24 hours plus we now know a couple of
minutes
uh which results in a leap year but but
they measured
24 hours then they began to see the sun
there were sophisticated
sightings ten thousand two thousand
astrologers ago
when er when um agriculture began
they began to oh we got a plant at a
certain time when
they started planting and looking to the
sun and the rain
and what was going to happen for their
crops for their to live
they started paying more attention to
what the stars were doing what the sun
was doing
yeah would you forget the mesopotamian
agricultural yeah agricultural
revolution because of that time
between going from hunter-gatherers into
agriculturally
being able to sustain ourselves
agriculture
began the civilization right exactly
stop
eating each other hunting each other the
cannibalism when did we stop that that's
that's that that
um that happened last night it's still
happening yeah
well it was in certain tribes
yeah i don't believe i don't believe the
instinct was to cannibalize
i think the instinct like it is in
nature for the
male of the herd or the
pride or whatever kicks the
animals out except for the and the
females as well
the the the pride the lion the male
lion the yearlings all go in
horses the stallion
pushes the yearlings of both of the
breeds i believe
both sex is out certainly the males
go so there's no inbreeding nature has
given us
a uh intuitive law that there's no
inbreeding and how that works i don't
know
how does a father not you know i don't
i think that instinct isn't necessarily
it's culturally there
but not necessarily in a human being's
mind but
eating somebody else i i think is
intuitive
we're in in our intuition repulsively
repulses that
perfect word but some
tribes in the world have made it
a religious ceremony where you eat the
heart or you eat the flesh of
as a ceremonial enemy or yeah yeah
or to gain the strength of yeah phil
it's
it's really thank you thank you for
coming
well it's been a joy i really appreciate
it i'm glad to have met you but michael
i
i i'm just who's your favorite football
team by the way
well the rams but they didn't do so well
they got their asses kicked
oh god it hurts it hurts you [ __ ]
man i used to watch joe montana him and
what was the other guy took his place
over
oh steve young steve young was good too
both
i saw uh an interview with steve young
and he said um
he lived 20 minutes away from the
stadium
but it took him two hours to he drew
around the
studio stayed in for two hours he was
lost
from concussions yes yes
a lot of these guys i played in the nfl
for six years i was an offensive tackle
and guard played in jacksonville with
the jags for four years i was about 325.
oh my god i'm about 250.
geez you're so you're kind of a slim
good-looking guy
just leaned down man i had to get rid of
that you know that was
all that armor fred dryer's a good
friend of mine and he led that movement
about
eating not eating from the training
table but yeah vegetables
i love fred yeah yeah no i mean it's all
about how you eat
how you take care of yourself and at
that time i had to pack on all that
armor so that i could perform out there
wow but um yeah uh
anyway it's great to have you here bill
thank you it was joy and uh
absolutely you guys absolutely thank you
so much
oh thank you dude mike yes great episode
brother always with you my friend
yes sir thank you thank you for
everything well listen
i take um bill as being like a really
extreme like
intellectual pacifist like yeah
bill's the man dude i mean what else are
we gonna say
enlightened he's an enlightened bill
definitely
um well anyway thank you everybody for
tuning in canada either man montreal i
think he's from america
yeah i know hey i just want to say one
more thing
what do you think when eddie murphy said
you you you [ __ ] a purple [ __ ] or a
green [ __ ] remember the thing
eddie murphy on raw
hey everybody thanks for tuning in this
special episode of hot boxing
uh oh you can stream the podcast on
apple and podcast one
until next time i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson saying
so long peace out of here
that was awesome that was awesome oh
michael
you're so revealing and so good it's
good to know you man
get some lipo in here dude
[Music]
[Music]
you